hier soir m6 diffusait un nouvel épisode
de l'amour est dans le pré où on a pu
voir une bénédiction de moutons plus des
chats en europe est née des clients ou
curchod groupe
mais aussi valentin l'agriculteur un peu
trop à l'aise à table pour une première
rencontre avec les proches de sa
prétendante le matin on est tous qui
colmate
voici tout on sait qu'à cannes datant
matin
mais fait des blagues parfois un peu
rentrent dedans mais c'est comme il est
quoi musculation tout retenu l'attention
des téléspectateurs c'est le bon hervé
qui est de plus en plus à l'aise depuis
qu'il a découvert le plaisir de la chair
c'est carrément devenu un pro des blacks
de l'udc attendu pendant le bout du
bateau bien sûr du gonfle sur taille que
le vent trop polis vont-ils que ça ça me
stéphanie a beau être un peu relou avec
lui tu fais piquer une tête si tu veux
mais moi c'est énorme bon tu verras pas
les travailleurs bref va beaucoup de
beurre qui normalement visiblement ça
les a pas empêchés de remettre encore le
couvert les petits coquins c'est une
belle soirée qui s'annonce plus que
flanché j'espère qu'il me parlait ni
stature et bien tu tombes il est moins
bon
[Musique]
et c'est normal que ce soit déjà l'avant
dernier épisode de la saison parce que
les scènes romantiques du lundi soir
vont vraiment nous manquer non tous en
fait je me suis grattée les faits
la main
c'est bon on a faim magnétosphère la
peine de tenir comme ça on dirait qu'on
a pris c'est bernard qui se sent tout
débute animée wakfu oui c'est non c'est
sympa et demeure plus on va passer à
jouer ensemble pourquoi d'ailleurs mes
animaux en plus ça me fait plaisir parce
que je crois qu'on va redistribuer à des
assauts c'est important à la spa c'est
bien je vous connais tel point que
demain vous inquiétez pas demain on va
travailler ensemble toute la journée ça
vous fait plaisir quelle angoisse mais
la journée oui d'accord je la vois d'ici
mais tu comprends rien bon alors c'est
quoi la question sur l'élection la
passion l'a pas de questions non
pourquoi tu mais non j'ai envie de dire
non
simon mais je pense que je suis coincé
que j'ai un vrai problème avec ce
programme hervé évidemment qu'il est
touchant évidemment qu'il est adorable
évidemment qu'on est heureux pour lui
évidemment qu'il a trouvé l'amour est
aussi le sexe mais malgré tout j'ai
beaucoup de mal avec cette séquence là
j'ai beaucoup de mal avec ces séquences
là je trouve qu'on utilise sa libido on
utilise le fait qu'il se soit révélé à
lui-même et moi je trouve qu il ya un
côté voyeur et voilà il a l'air heureux
mais malgré tout je suis gêné je me sens
toujours à doha la semaine d'un je suis
arrivé je suis une autre ruse en fait je
suis pas j'aime pas ça me plaît pas oui
madame un mois justement je peux je
pense que pour une fois que ce soit à la
télé nous appelle d'où toi
de torcy
alors voilà on l'a perdue jouera pas je
trouve que ce soit j'ai jeté de
nouvelles substances aujourd'hui je
trouve qu elles mêmes sont merveilleuses
reste à tester
[Musique]
infinitésimale
qui me frappe c'est toi [ __ ] le chat
quand vous avez testé cours des choses
extraordinaires
alors attention en revanche pas te parle
avec l'accès des substances licites bien
sûr nous pas illicite et merci tu
viendras tout est licite
ou tel mais si tu sais quand je suppose
dans ce dépôt
je trouve que juste
alors maintenant aux bébés diamond
actuel la terreur sur les réseaux ou à
la télé je trouve que pour une fois on
voit une image saine de l'amour et du
sexe et moi ça me plaît justement de
voir ce côté là du sexe et de l'amour
que toutes les choses qu'on voit des
choses des questions sur l'équipe abel à
la télé même moi ça me plaît je trouve
ça ça vous intéresse pas du tout ce que
celle ci s'était épris du cbd non parce
que les gens qui disent de personnes
cinq ans je ne vais pas regarder votre
portable en fait
[Applaudissements]
venez l'abbé denis c'est le producteur
qui m'a parlé dans l'oreille il m'a dit
les gens s'interrogent 1 vous avez pris
quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à soit belle la gamine
non mais je crois qu'il a pris du cbd et
détendue et détendu à lausanne ont un
peu trop fait gaffe qu'elle fait partie
voilà qu'est ce qui l'a amené tiens
c'est pas la peine de rester derrière
l'îlot on vous a vu
merci vous allez marcher comme ça
pendant que maintenant
on a une année difficile fall et lui
répondre justement parce que kelly vous
me décevez vous aimez l'authenticité le
naturel ce qui est vrai mais oui mais là
c'est faux c'est scénarisé
on se gratte les faits sa joie que c'est
le monsieur ces salons médias il a fait
les cours
flaubert hervé stéphanie ont beau encore
beaucoup fait parler d'eux rappelez-vous
dans l'épisode précédent il se confier
sur leur première nuit d'amour et donner
beaucoup de détails et hier soir on a
retrouvé hervé et stéphane est encore
très très chaud ouais ouais c'était
juste pour le kiff on a sélectionné la
version longue du doigt dans la bouche
c'est le nom à gauche
tu as peur
non mais tu vas me faire confiance à
me faire confiance je vais pas faire de
bêtises j'aimerais pas comme le soc
[Musique]
non doucement pas les dents a
en fait je me suis grattée
[Rires]
ses salariés
[Musique]
non mais moi je suis désolé on peut pas
dire tout et son contraire parce que
vous n'avez pas de dire que justement
des autres étaient des clients qu'ils
étaient là et ça va le père fouras côté
ils sont trop nature voilà pas du tout
sa nature parce que ça vous plaît pas
parce que vous êtes assurés et de
l'autre côté quand quand c'est un peu un
peu joué alors la coop mais six mille
pâtes à tartiner marron il dit monsieur
la télé fais tout ça drôle toi et
toi tu récupères catalan j'aime bien la
peinture bi-ton non non non non mais
quoi bon bah je rêve mais j'aurais donne
rien mais
franchement dans l'émission s'ouvre là
tout le monde
est en train de devenir complètement
ça ne se fait pas ces réseaux marié et
maria question si ce ne serait pas non
non ça je fais pauvres ils arborent non
nous d'abord aux bouffes pas de pâte à
tartiner lille frau machines apple
ah oui le matin comme ça y'a pas de pain
c'est bon pour la danse yapo la couleur
mais
ça donne envie en tout cas ben oui tu as
droit levant le matin ah oui le matin le
reste de soubré veille après ses bons
tiendrai moi j'ai sali le matin ah ouais
c'est pour ça qu'il allait donc
pourrissent pas de contrat à voir vous
correctement on avait une mélée
magnifique année super
coq l attaque claude millette du chef
les ponots films se font pas fier
[Applaudissements]